vous êtes une super maman je sais pas
avec trevor ça va plutôt bien phoebe par
contre avec moi le partage à rire ça
c'est normal c'est une ado geek mal dans
sa peau
s'installer ici c'est peut-être une
chance de recommencer à zéro je voudrais
qu'elle se lâche un peu ça veut dire
et tu fais quoi ici à ce merville
on n'a plus d'argent mon grand père nous
a laissé une vieille ferme flippante en
pleine cambrousse ton père et
l'administratif ça faisait 2 on était
toujours à deux doigts se faire couper
le courant il nous a rien laissé du tout
je ne dirais pas rien du tout
j'ai choisi le break tout pourri c'est
le seul qui avait un moteur
il se passe quoi ici
dans une ville qui est loin de toute
faille tectonique la terre tremble tous
les jours
c'est peut-être l'apocalypse
ego n'est pas venu ici par hasard
êtes vous dérangé par des bruits
étranges au milieu de la nuit
vous avez eu la chair de poule dans
votre cave ou votre grenier
vous êtes vous jamais trouvé nez à nez
avec un revenant à spec trois photos
j'y crois pas
vous avez entendu quelque chose
s'approche
toute la ville
en mode ou aquitaine
cv
elle aurait sans doute
à vous croire
on est fermé